bonsoir anne rose et de radio merci
d'être avec nous pour évoquer cette
situation malheureusement très critique
également en espagne nouveau record de
contamination le chiffre fait froid dans
le dos on l'a dit 39000 l'effet des
fêtes
effectivement c'est un chiffre qui fait
foi fois dans le dos vous voyez
l'espagne à 20 millions d'habitants en
moins que que la france et nous avons à
peu près entre dix et quinze mille cas
de contamination des plus quotidiens
n'ont que la france ce sont des chiffres
extrêmement compliqué mais c'est vrai
aussi que l'espagne ne vit pas le même
situation qu'en france dont la mesure où
par exemple les centres culturels les
théâtres les salles des concerts les les
restaurants les bars sont ouverts ce qui
n'est pas le cas en france donc ça
pourrait aussi donc expliquer ce nombre
des cas des contaminations quotidien que
quand vous disiez était hier des 39
milles aujourd'hui le ministère parler
dans les 35000 lors des 24 dernières
heures et surtout ce chiffre aussi est
très important pour un pays comme
l'espagne plus des 50 premiers morts on
se souvient qu'en mars et en avril
dernier le confinement avait été très
strict en espagne peut-être même que
strict qu'en france puisque même les
enfants n'avaient pas le droit de de
sortir pourquoi c'est ont autant
relâcher avec autant de permissivité par
rapport en tout cas à la france a on
vient d'avoir un restaurateur
le pauvre qui se peignaient voilà ça
fait des mois qu'ils étaient fermées il
n'en voyait pas le bout alors il ya dia
principalement deux raisons qui peuvent
expliquer ça donc la ligne de raison que
je dis pas la première mais l'idée
raison c'est certainement la raison
économique l'espagne est un pays qui
comme tous les maux rope a beaucoup
souffert économiquement avec une perte
de chiffre d'affaires et de pib assez
importante pour pour le pays
l'espagne a donc décidé effectivement de
remettre un peu en selle les
professionnels les restaurateurs et
l'hôtel et l'hôtellerie ce qui est
toujours pas le cas du côté de la france
pour essayer dé sauver et des samples
puisque l'espagne était
fortement touché par le chômage et
notamment les chômage des jeunes et puis
il ya une deuxième raison qui est la
région la raison politique vous avez
aujourd'hui le gouvernement espagnol est
un gouvernement de coalition qui
gouverne en minorité qui a eu fort à
faire avec les différents gouvernements
régionaux qui demandait lors du premier
confirmant avoir plus de pouvoirs pour
pouvoir gérer la pandémie et le
gouvernement a décidé lors de cette
deuxième vague espagnol dé la pandémie
tout simplement des laisser le
gouvernement autonome gérer la pandémie
c'est pour cela et haute en france on
est en train de tout concentrer autant
en espagne
la vaccination par exemple est géré par
le gouvernement autonome et c'est comme
disait votre correspondante du côté de
barcelone c'est chaque région qui
détermine quels sont les secteurs
d'activités économiques qui peuvent
ouvrir ou pas et quels sont les horaires
à respecter ou pas donc à barcelone vous
pouvez avoir effectivement des
couvre-feux qui sont établies avant 12h
et en andalousie vous avez des
couvre-feux qui sont établies à minuit
donc vous voyez la raison économique et
la raison politique ont fait que
l'espagne a pris un chemin différent par
rapport à la france alors 39000
contamination aujourd'hui enfin en tout
cas en 24 heures on le disait un chiffre
impressionnant
est ce qu'on doit également assez
varieront dont on parle maintenant
quotidiennement aux anglais sud
africains ont peut-être même japonais
effectivement mais il ya des cas qui ont
été déjà détecté en espagne que ce soit
hollande à lucic et ce soit dans les
îles baléares et dans d'autres régions
du nord de l'espagne
donc on fait très attention à cette
variante anglais qui arrivent aussi du
côté de l'espagne c'est vrai que la
vaccination en espagne marche des
piquets depuis le 27 décembre quand elle
a commencé en tout ont toute l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est un peu moins de 700
milles espagnols qui ont déjà été
vaccinées et encore une fois ce sont les
gouvernements autonomes aux régionales
qui gère justement la vaccination avec
comme en france à une priorité qui est
donnée aux personnes âgées qui vivent
dans les ehpad miss aussi bien
évidemment au personnel sanitaire qui
est en contact avec ces personnes et
avec la population de façon générale une
dernière question sur les vaccins vous
en parliez tout à l'heure comment ce
test passant en espagne on est à près de
600000 vacciner c'est un bon rythme pour
vous 1 24% de la population comment
réagissent les espagnols ont déjà la
première des choses c'est que les
espagnols sont favorables à la
vaccination pour la plupart et ce qui
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à il ya
quelques jours en france donc c'est vrai
quand je vous disais que c'est plutôt
les régions qui gère donc les plans des
vaccinations et donc il ya des régions
effectivement qui sont à des
pourcentages quand même assez importante
de vaccination entre 20 et 40 40 % delà
de la population aujourd'hui je vous dis
c'est un peu moins décès de son 1000
vaccinés avec un peu près un million
deux cent mille dos qui sont déjà
arrivés en espagne
en attendant carif le reste des vaccins
qui vont être envoyés et qui a été
négocié par l'union européenne
merci beaucoup renoncer à dorado d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france